[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire cette émission est consacrée
est la cartographie est la perception de
l'univers dans lequel nous vivons je
suis je là vous un passionné de cartes
si l'on veut comprendre quelque chose à
ce qui se passe sur cette planète il
faut s'intéresser à la géographie
c'était donc avec un immense plaisir que
je reçois aujourd'hui laurent maréchaux
qui publie au cherche midi les
défricheurs du monde un beau livre
magnifiquement illustré sur les
géographes qui ont dessiné la terre
laurent maréchaux bonjour vous n'êtes
pas géographe vous même vous êtes
écrivain et voyageur
oui mais et c'est mes lectures et mes
voyages qui m'ont conduit est géographe
et si on prend les géographes de
l'antiquité pour et et géographe au
maire était poète hérodote était
historien et c'est leur curiosité du
monde qui les a conduit à s'intéresser à
la géographie donc modestement je suis
dans leur lignée et l'on commence comme
toujours par notre époque qu'est ce qui
la caractérise ouais si l'image que vous
avez choisi alors pourquoi celle-ci est
bien parce que on est dans un monde où
il ya de moins en moins deux héros est
un héros au sens du dictionnaire c'est
quelqu'un qui réalise un exploit et qui
fait preuve d'un courage exceptionnel et
jean le cam sur son bateau qui a quand
même une douzaine d'années réalise un
véritable exploit puisque il tient tête
aux nouveaux bateaux qui ont les
dernières techniques du progrès et il
fait preuve d'un courage exceptionnel
parce que quand les autres contourne les
dépressions lui vaut au coeur de la
dépression pour gagner du temps et puis
dans le héros il ya une autre qualité
c'est la solidarité et on l'a vu avec
kevin escoffier pendant toute une nuit
jean le cam à tourner en rond et a
cherché à récupérer son camarade et il
l'a fait avec une grande humilité et
beaucoup de modestie et il nous permet
de rêver
et dans cette époque impôts grise il
constitue une véritable lumière et bien
commençons
[Musique]
alors laurent maréchaux avant d'attaquer
plus particulièrement votre livre il
faut comprendre quelque chose me
semble-t-il c'est que les cartes c'est
un art difficile
et pour cause les cartes du monde que
nous connaissons aujourd'hui que nous
utilisons sont toutes fausses
il faut quand même le rappeler je
propose de regarder la carte la plus
connue celle qu'on apprend à l'école
c'est une projection de mercator on
reviendra sur bar 14 tout à leur passif
il fait partie de ces géographe qui ont
défriché le monde mais c'est terme de
mercator telle que nous la connaissons
elle est complètement fausse
c'est à dire que les distances les à la
forme des pays est juste mais les
distances sont fausses
les les surfaces les superficies des
pays sont fausses
l'afrique convoite au centre est bien
trop petite par rapport à l'europe le
brésil si on le compare avec le
groenland qui est tout en haut blanc le
on a l'impression que le groenland est
plus petite elle est plus petite que
brésil alors est plus grand que le
brésil pardonnez moi alors que le brésil
est quatre fois plus vaste que le
groenland
voilà c'est complètement faux et
pourtant en garde ses cartes là vous
avez un avis là-dessus l'euro maréchaux
oui j'ai un avis parce que c'est la
perversité des cartes le but de la carte
c'est de donner à voir le monde en un
seul coup d'oeil
or les distances qui séparent ou les
hémisphères où les confins ouest ouest
est ouais tu ne perds man ne permettent
pas d'apporter le mot non d'un seul coup
d'oeil et c'est donc le côté pervers de
la carte qui pour notre plaisir ou celui
de voyageurs veut nous donner une
approche synthétique alors qu'au
contraire la carte nécessite de
s'étendre de de se présenter de
s'élargir pour que finalement le
voyageur qui est le destinataire de la
carte puisse se déplacer quand je
regarde votre votre carte
si je veux aller de l'est de l'afrique à
l'ouest de l'afrique
bon je vois comment y aller mais je ne
sais pas comment il allait donc la carte
ne répond que partiellement à ma volonté
de
deux déplacements qui est la deuxième
raison des cartes c'est à dire aider à
voyager d'ailleurs les trajets sont
également en faux puisque si on regarde
on se dit tiens prenons entre new york
et moscou
le trajet logiquement il passe par
londres c'est ce que c'est la pression
qu'on a là il passe par londres est en
fait en réalité non ils passent la vraie
trajectoire elle passe par l'islande
plus au nord mais tout ça c'est pour une
raison simple c'est un globe terrestre
et que quand on létale
forcément il vient faut voir c'est la
deuxième remarque que je voulais faire
c'est effectivement la rotondité de la
terre
et comme la terre est ronde dès qu'on
veut la transcrire sur un planisphère
on a obligé de biaiser on ne rend pas
compte de la réalité
alors suite un battant il ya quand même
beaucoup de gens qui savent que cette
carte est fausse donc on s'est dit on va
en prendre une autre c'est la projection
de galles peter ce qu'on va voir tout de
suite parce que dans celle ci les les
distances
en tout cas les surfaces les superficies
pardonnez moi elles sont juste là on
voit que l'afrique est énorme par
rapport à l'europe
la précédente projection était centré
sur l'europe
c'est ce qui donnait ses mauvaises
superficie de l'afrique et de l'amérique
du sud
l'envoi que les superficies sont bonnes
les distances sont bonnes mais en
revanche c'est les formes qui ne sont
plus sommes là tout et tout est déformé
c'est le cas de le dire
et plus on se rapproche des pôles plus
est déformé la le groenland ou ce qu'il
en reste n'a rien à voir avec ce qu'il
est en réalité en fait on n'y arrivera
jamais on peut penser qu'avec les
satellites et des visions satellite du
monde on peut avoir une approche plus
juste et le vrai grand bond de la
cartographie ça a été quand même le
recours à des satellites pour
représenter et imaginer le monde
alors maintenant et orient sont noués ce
livre passionnant
dans ce livre vous fait commencé le 1er
défricheurs du monde pour vous c'est au
maire au maire c'est le viiie siècle
avant jésus-christ maire vous l'avez dit
c'est un poète il nous raconte la guerre
de troie et et voilà au fond la
représentation
du monde la perception du monde qui
avait top d'homère à son époque elle est
ici donc on peut la décrire comment
alors comme vous l'avez dit au maire
c'est un poète et l'iliade et l'odyssée
c'était deschamps allégorique qui était
racontée au cours d'europe 1 où étaient
invités le peuple les notables et ses
chants allégorie qu'ils avaient pour but
de répondre aux questions philosophiques
existentielle du monde c'est à dire
qu'est ce qu'on fait sur terre
à quoi ressemble le monde dans lequel on
vit où est ce que je me trouve sur ce
monde et par rapport à ces questions
philosophiques au maire lui a apporté
une réponse politique c'est à dire que
il est parti de la guerre de troie et
les parties d'un de ses personnages
emblématiques qui est agile et il a
demandé un forgeron qui ai failli stoos
de représenter le monde sur le bouclier
d'achille et la question qui se posait
c'était qu'est-ce qui était exactement
aux cèpes terre et en décrivant ce
bouclier au maire apporte une première
réponse il dit les êtres humains vous
les achéens vous vivez sur un disque
plein qui entouré d'un fleuve océan et
le ciel est supporté par des grandes
murailles et à partir de là on avait par
rapport au cosmos par rapport aux
étoiles que les gens contempler leur
lors de ces dîners il avait une première
représentation
mais cette représentation il suffisait
pas et donc au maire qui savait que les
grecs est un peuple de voyageurs il a
voulu apporter un deuxième complément
d'information et à travers le voyage de
l'iss
il a commencé à dessiner une carte de la
méditerranée et il a commencé après dans
l'iliade à nous avoir montré lorient à
nous avoir montré l'occident et pourquoi
en mer un géographe c'est parce que le
pape de la géographie qu'un autre grec
qui s'appelle strabon quand il fait
l'histoire de la géographie
il considère que c'est la première fois
dans l'histoire du monde que quelqu'un
s'intéresse à la description de la terre
et de l'univers
m et que quelqu'un nous propose une
carte de voyage ou un routier alors
après au maire et le disque plat entouré
par le fleuve océans
on arrive à un accident dhr lui c'est le
vième siècle avant jésus-christ pour
anaximandre voilà ce qu'est la terre
c'est autre chose alors un accident de
saint wendel lui il a du mal en tant qu
êtres rationnels à croire aux fadaises
des dieux qui aurait créé la terre que
remis des colonnes et c est donc en tant
que astronome mathématicien
il va apporter sa propre réflexion et
dire que finalement la terre c'est un
corps ferrique qui flotte dans un espace
indéfini et pour représenter cette terre
il va dire qu'il ressemble au trot sont
d'une colonne et on voit sur cette carte
le tronçon de cette colonne qui a été
dessiné par éclater et on trouve les
trois premiers continents
on trouve l'europe qui représente la
moitié de cette sphère
et on trouve à gauche là la libye et
l'asie et comme on le disait tout à
l'heure le point faible de cette
deuxième représentation du monde sait
que elle veut en un clin d'oeil nous
donnait à représenter le monde mais ses
contours sont grossiers elle est
miniaturisé
elle ne nous apprend pas grand chose sur
le monde alors il ya éclaté vous l'avait
dit et capter ces c'est disons 500 ans
avant avant jésus-christ et etc était
lui il va nous montrer voilà le monde
selon eqecat et donc on reste dans
l'idée du cylindre éventuellement mais
on l idée un peu plus précise de ce
qu'est le monde à l'époque vous l'avez
dit donc à l'europe au nord laly
l'afrique ça se contente d'être là
l'idée la libye et
enfin c'est comme ça qu'on l'appelle et
puis à droite il ya le le début de de
l'asie qu'a t il est important en lui un
way est captée d'abord il faut savoir
que en mer n'a dessiné aucune carte un
maximum n'a dessiné aucune cape et qui a
été c'est le premier qui a représenté au
sens enregistré / / / d'épinac ce une
représentation du monde alors à la
différence des red hot
il apporte quand même quelque chose de
colossal c'est que sur la carte sim et
des fleuves et il met quand même
quelques indications topographiques ou
géométriques on voit les les monts du
caucase on voit les grands fleuves et on
commence à avoir les comprend et on
commence à avoir une représentation plus
détaillée
maintenant si je veux me déplacer avec
cette carte je peux aller nulle part
parce que si je veux aller d'un point à
un autre
je sais où je me trouve je suis en libye
en europe ou en asie
mais je ne sais pas par où passait et je
ne connais pas les difficultés du
terrain
hérodote vous l'avez site hérodote lui
ça compte beaucoup parce que c'est le
annoncé aristote hérodote lui non plus
ne dessine pas de carte mais on va le
voir ça c'est leur représentation du
monde la perception du monde selon
hérodote là ça commence à se préciser un
notamment du côté de l'asie alors et est
ce qui est très intéressant chez
hérodote c'est que redoute c'est pas un
géographe san historien et la
préoccupation de cet historien c'est que
les générations futures puissent se
souvenir de ce qui s'est passé et ce qui
a marqué cette époque c'est c'est cesser
les guerres qui ont opposé à eux les
persos grecque et l'huile donc pour
raconter ses guerres et des jouets
prendre mon bâton de marcheur et je vais
me rendre sur le terrain afin de voir
d'une part qu'elle est la topologie
quels étaient les difficultés naturelles
auxquelles il est confronté et surtout
avoir des témoignages oraux
des peuples qui se sont battus et qui
racontent qu'elles étaient les modes de
vie quelles étaient les habitudes
comment les gens étaient vêtus et
hérodote et le premier qui va ajouter je
dirais de l'ethnographie et de la
sociologie pour donner un sens aux
cartes il va commencer a indiqué les
populations et il va faire en sorte que
cette charte puisse être utilisé ou
puisse servir à d'autres hommes
politiques pour poursuivre leur
politique de conquête
alors il faut bien pour réaliser que les
cette époque là tout le monde pense que
la terre est plate encore il faut un
formidable effort d'imagination pour
imaginer qu on est sur autre chose
qu'une paire plate alors c'est là où au
tout à l'heure vous avez mentionné
aristote et aristote et le premier qui
va dire que la terre est une sphère
alors si c'est le premier à dire que la
terre est une sphère
pour lui elle est concaves ou convexes
mais reste immobile donc c'est le début
du jour centrisme c'est à dire que des
jarres du monde de leur histoire
déjà on voit que sur ses cartes le monde
est centrée sur le bassin méditerranéen
mais deuxièmement toutes les pierres
tourne autour de la terre c'est à dire
que aristote reconnaît que la terre est
une sphère concaves et convexes et cossu
il ya les sphères d d d d étoiles et des
lunes mais la terre ne bouge pas et
reste immobile et on peut supposer que
les étoiles et les lunes peuvent bouger
ce qui n'est pas vrai pour les étoiles
alors là on l'a vu la chaîne la
représentation sphérique non on va voir
ce qu'il imaginait au milieu
aristote il faut rappeler que aristote
c'est le seul professeur d'alexandre le
grand
c'est lui qui va lui expliquer comment
est le monde et ensuite alexandre à
l'âge de 20 ans va s'élancer pour le
conquérir le monde à ce moment là le
système d'aristote
le voilà alors lorsque vous venez de
dire c'est très intéressant parce que
c'est la finalité de la géographie c'est
à dire que la géographie
elle doit permettre aux conquérants de
conquérir donc de d'aller en quête de
nouveaux espaces de se déplacer et de
savoir comment les atteindre et ensuite
de les administrer
mais la géographie elle ne peut évoluer
dans la mesure où on n'a pas d'avion et
pas de satellite uniquement par les
conquêtes militaires et quand aristote
part aux confins de l'asie
il emmène avec lui des ddd des
correspondants de guerre qui sont
censées noter tous les pays qui
traversent nos télés distance noter la
faune et la deuxième chose qui fait pour
faire plaisir à aristote c'est que et
demande à ses capitaines quand il arrive
à l'indus de construire un bateau et de
rentrer par la mer et on voit que ce
sont les conquêtes militaires qui
permettent à la géographie progressaient
alors que les géographies permet aux
conquêtes militaires de progresser c'est
la poule et l'oeuf
alors ensuite arrive eratosthène qui lui
va bénéficier des conquêtes d'alexandre
donc on en sait beaucoup plus voilà le
monde tel qu'on se le représente le
monde grec après les conquêtes
d'alexandre on voit que c'est allé
beaucoup plus loin du côté de l'inde
ils sont allés jusqu'à jusqu'à l'indus
vous l'avez dit mais on voit aussi que
de l'autre côté on a découvert la grande
bretagne
on commence à se rapprocher de
l'arctique alors avant toute chose il
faut quand même rendre à hérat tostan ce
qui appartient eratosthène avant lui la
géographie n'existe pas et c'est le
premier qui a cherché un nom pour
dénommer le travail de cartes et de
bibliographie qui fait
et c'est le premier qui a pensé appeler
cette science de la représentation du
monde géographie et géographe agne il ya
le mot géo qui veut dire terre et ce qui
est intéressant c'est qu'il ya le mot
graf heinz qui veut dire à la fois
écrire et dessiner et donc la
représentation de la terre elle est à la
fois littéraire et elle est en même
temps cartographiques et la deuxième
chose que fait eratosthène c'est que lui
il va chercher à se servir de la
géométrie pour mieux comprendre le monde
et plus que la précision des choses il
va créer ce qu'on appelle des fragiles
c'est à dire des ensembles dans lequel
on va regrouper au les terres des ddd
même continent
et on voit que avec ses fragiles qui
sont des représentations grossière on a
quand même un monde qui est encore très
déformée mais c'est une marrant de voir
que la l'italie par exemple la botte
elle est assez proche de la réalité si
on s'approche bien de la grèce par
exemple c'est un peu la même chose on
commence à avoir des notions en dépit du
fait qu'on ne peut pas s'élever dans les
airs qu'on n'a pas de cette élite
on commence à dessiner un peu plus
précisément et alors ça c'est pour une
raison très simple c'est que ce sont les
grecs donc qui sont à la base de la
représentation du monde
anaximandre eratosthène etc
ils ont vécu soit le long de la turquie
soit en italie soit le long de la limite
et ils décrivent des espaces où ils ont
tous voyagé et où ils ont pu mesurer à
eux mêmes la réalité des choses et
l'appréhender
alors on voit bien que l'afrique il ya
très peu de gens qui vont à l'afrique
personne ne connaît donc ça reste quand
même très imagée et en dehors
d'alexandre il ya peu de gens qui ont
été aux confins de l'asie donc cesser
cette ce contact direct avec les
territoires où ils ont vécu qui permet
justement d'affiner les contours du
bassin méditerranéen par rapport aux
autres grandes volume aux autres grands
espaces et alors la découverte de là
en bretagne de la scandinavie le moment
où on s'approche de l'arctique ses
contemporains d'alexandre ça alors il ya
eu un grand navigateur qui s'appelle
philéas le massaliotes qui a été le
premier à remonter
je dirais jusqu'à tullet et la plupart
eu des des cartographes se sont servis
de ces carnets de voyage et ça explique
bien comment évoluer la cartographie
c'est à dire que si vous prenez les
grand cartographe il était souvent dans
des ports et ils prélèvent est prélevé
le livre de bord des bateaux il le
recopier et leur rendait et ce sont les
les marins qui ont permis justement à la
cartographie de progresser et alors ce
qui est intéressant c'est que on est
toujours dans le même système
si les marins ont besoin de cartes
pourront naviguer c'est eux qui font
progresser les cartes et à un moment
c'est là où la géographie va se bloquer
parce que les marins n'auront plus assez
de cartes pour avancer notamment pour se
rendre dans dans les indes et les cartes
ne pourront pas évoluer parce que les
marins ne peuvent pas y aller alors là
on arrive à apt olé mais claude ptolémée
c'est le 2e siècle avant jésus-christ
tollé mais lui non
après jésus-christ après jésus-christ
pardonnez moi ma langue a fourché
là on commence à voir le globe terrestre
alors tu allais mais c'est le premier
qui a fait une mappemonde il métaux les
messins c'est un mathématicien l'huile
et là c'est peu voyagé et son obsession
c'était drôle en de recenser 8000 points
à travers le monde et de trouver les
coordonnées en longitude et la latitude
est ce que va faire dans les mains c'est
le premier qui va quadriller le monde
entre mairie vient et parallèle et qui
va vouloir que chaque ville qui figure
sur les cartes puisse être recensées en
latitude et longitude est alors on
arrive à un point qu'on n'a pas encore
soulevé c'est que le problème de fond
pour dessiner une carte
il faut savoir quelle est la
circonférence de la terre
or en fonction de la circonférence les
cartes n'ont pas la même figure le le le
premier justement qui s'est attardé sur
la circonférence de la terre et dont on
a parlé tout à l'heure c'est et rasht
hautaine et lui il est parti d'un
constat que le 21 juin le zénith n'était
pas le même entre alexandrie willy où il
habitait la ville de sienne et il a
cherché à calculer à comprendre la
raison de cette explication est il à
calculer l'angle que fait le phare de
sienne avec les rayons d'alexandrie avec
les rayons du soleil
il a mesuré la distance il l'a évaluée à
7 degrés 12
il l'a x 360 degrés et il en a conclu
que la circonférence de la terre était
de 39 1350 km versus les 40000 75km
d'aujourd'hui et est donc là on est
quand même au 3e siècle avant
jésus-christ et on a une découverte
fondamentale et outre le fait qu'ils
restent hautaines et donner un nom à la
géographie
c'est le premier qui de façon
scientifique et précise à mesurer la
circonférence du monde
il faut savoir que avant lui aristote le
mesurer à 80 mille kilomètres et donc
par la suite quand on verra les grandes
aventures de la navigation
on va se caler sur tollé mais et
ptolémée malheureusement lui va enlever
au sud lui degrés et à l'est et l'ouest
une partie de la réalité de la terre et
on va se retrouver avec une
circonférence de la terre qui fera
trente mille kilomètres ce qu'il faut ce
sera la navigation des grands
navigateurs et des grands découvreurs
on y reviendra parce qu'effectivement
c'est une des astuces et palpitant mai
mais reste au dessus sur ceux sur cette
cette planète qui ressemble enfin à la
nôtre on est au 2e siècle après
jésus-christ on sait que la terre est
ronde et qu'elles flottent dans l'espace
le ski est ce qui est intéressant c'est
que c'est un tel progrès que pendant
pratiquement huit siècles plus rien ne
bougera le but de ptolémée
ça a été deux
de compiler de valider et de mettre à
jour et son travail a été tellement
parfait que non seulement les géographes
occidentaux sont serviront mais 71 mais
qui va être à la base de la géographie
arabes et tous les grand géographe arabe
vont reprendre les connaissances de
ptolémée pour ensuite les adapter
multiplier les cartes et s'en servir
dans leur conquête notamment des côtes
d'afrique
on va voir comment il voyait le bond de
l'est mais voilà alors là on voit que
c'est très très précis 1
c'est un vrai travail de géographes et
ça commence on voit le tracé des des
parallèles et des latitudes
alors ce qui est intéressant c'est que
tollé mais qui était pragmatique et dont
le seul but était d les gens à voyager a
compris que d'un côté on avait besoin
d'un planisphère globale qui
représentait la terre mais surtout il
fallait faire des déclinaisons
régionales donc tollé mais non seulement
ne s'est pas contenté de faire une carte
du monde mais il a fait 26 carte
régionale qui permettent donc aux marins
ou commerciaux etc
quand ils se déplacent de se situer avec
plus de précision on fait une pause
laurent maréchaux on se retrouve juste
après et on a encore beaucoup de cartes
a gardé toutes tirées évidemment de
votre livre
[Musique]
nous sommes toujours avec laurent
maréchaux l'auteur des défricheurs du
monde c'est géographe qui ont dessiné la
terre qui vient de paraître au cherche
midi avec une préface de jean de loisy
alors on en arrive aux grandes
découvertes laurent maréchaux et alors
il ya beaucoup de cartes un j'en ai
choisi certaines au détriment d'autres
il y en a une que j'ai trouvée
magnifique c'est cette carte portugaise
dont on ne connaît pas l'auteur
d'ailleurs on l'appelle la carte de
cantine au je crois un c'est ça parce
que c'est c'est le nom de celui qui l'a
qui la possédait et elle est fantastique
cette carte quand on la regarde pas ce
qu'elle est d'une précision est lucie
nantes et en plus les dessins qui
représentent les villes les comptoirs
autour de l'afrique sont magnifiques
oui alors il ya une raison c'est que
dans la conquête du monde
on a deux royaumes qui sont prédominants
il ya d'un côté le portugal et de
l'autre l'espagne et les grands
navigateurs ou en tout cas les
navigateurs qui vont se mettre au
service des espagnols et des portugais
vont être les premiers déjà à descendre
jusqu'au sud de l'afrique avec vasco de
gama qui passera le cap de bonne
espérance et ils vont tenir des carnets
de bord et des livres de bord et ils
vont pouvoir rapporter à des gens dont
on parlera peut-être comme benny b haïm
le fruit de leurs expéditions et c'est
la compilation de ces cartes maritimes
et des livres de bord de ces grands
marins qui permet à la fois aux cartes
de s'étendre et qui permet aux cartes de
s'enrichir par exemple quand les
navigateurs comme diego khiam vont
découvrir le gabon la guinée
ils vont rentrer dans les estuaires
ils vont voir la population ils vont
commencer à faire des petites
expéditions
ils vont rapporter des dessins d'animaux
et ils vont permettre aux illustrateurs
de donner des couleurs et de la vie à
ces cartes maritimes à l'origine
lorsqu'il faut bien voir aussi c'est que
le portugal
au moment où on fait cette carte est à
la pointe du progrès en europe 1 il a
les meilleurs astronomes il a les
meilleurs marins les seuls capables de
descendre de contourner l'afrique c'est
un exploit à l'époque ils vont aller
jusqu'en inde puis au japon ce qui est
absolument extraordinaire
et cela bien avant les autres ils ont
une avance extraordinaire à ce moment là
et ils ont un atout qui n'est pas
négligeable
c'est que ils ont le soutien des papes
parce que c'est le pays le plus
catholique et déjà les peuples se posent
sont préoccupés par delà la colonisation
des terres de pouvoir coloniser les âmes
et donc les papes catholiques vont
soutenir fortement et même
financièrement le portugal pour que
derrière l'expansionnisme territoriales
se prépare déjà la colle à la conquête
des âmes et c'est essentiellement
également pour des raisons financières
parce que une expédition coûte très cher
il n'y a pas forcément eu des marins
portugais ou espagnols
donc il faut avec dédé des doutes ya des
d'état l'air pouvoir acheter les
meilleurs et enroulé mais les meilleurs
équipages qui sont qui sont disponibles
sur le marché et ce qui est intéressant
c'est que lisbonne va devenir à la fois
la porte de sortie méditerranéenne mais
va également être le lieu de rencontre
de tous les grands navigateurs
on verra à la même époque magellan
christophe colomb benhaim benhaim dîné
ensemble se rencontrer échanger leurs
cartes et ça va véritablement être la
plaque tournante de la conquête du monde
et alors il ya deux choses intéressantes
d'abord on voit bien à quel point celui
qui est de la vence sur la cartographie
donc sur la géographie est de l'avant
sur tout le reste
et réciproquement plus on avance sur
tout le reste plus on va progresser en
cartographie mais ce qui est intéressant
aussi c'est que les portugais arrive au
japon et les japonais ont parfaitement
compris le problème
il vire c'était qu'ils ne veulent pas de
ces types qui se sont couverts de venir
de faire du commerce viennent conquérir
les âmes comme vous l'avez dit ils vont
persécuter les prêtres les quelques
prêtres qui arriveront à débarquer vont
les persécutés pour pas être converties
au christianisme
alors je vais ouvrir une parenthèse
parce que il ya quelque chose de très
important dont on n'a pas parlé et qui
explique justement pourquoi les
espagnols et les portugais ont eu cette
prédominance c'est à dire qu'autrefois
si vous preniez la république de venise
par exemple où les gros négociant
allemand
il passait par constantinople pour
gagner l'asie or en 1454 les turcs se
sont emparés de constantinople et il n'y
avait plus de conquête ni de voyages
possibles par terre et donc la seule
hypothèse c'était donc d'avoir recours à
la navigation maritime et là se poser la
question fondamentale c'est est ce qu'il
faut passer par l'est ou est-ce qu'il
faut passer par l'ouest
et quelle est la route la plus courte
pour justement gagné le japon avec ou
sans missionnaire avec ou sans marque
tyr et gagner également l'inde
alors vous avez prononcé son nom à
plusieurs reprises c'est martin benhaim
verte martin bmc le premier qui va faire
un globe terrestre
il faut rappeler la différence toutes
les cartes que nous avons vues sont des
mappemondes une mappemonde c'est une
carte plane un globe terrestre c'est un
globe terrestre et voilà le premier
celui de bm on est en 14 192 une date
importante c'est la date à laquelle
christophe que l'on part à la conquête
de ce qu'il ne sait pas être l'amérique
et au même moment y ait ce globe et avec
ce globe il ya la carte qui suivent qui
figure également dans votre livre c'est
qu'est ce que l'on connaît du monde
à ce moment là en 14 192 voilà on en
connaît ça
à droite l'afrique l'europe et et le
début de l'eurasie puis à gauche
l'extrême orient
le japon qu'on appelle cipango et c'est
là que l'on veut aller et quand on
regarde cette carte on voit bien que
pour que l'on il s'agit de partir par
l'ouest et de partir de séville pour
aller ainsi bongo c'est juste en face et
ça devrait pas poser de problème alors
alors là il faut en revenir à taulé mais
parce que je l'aimais est à la base de
deux de ce choix maritime
alors que on l'a vu eratosthène avait
considéré que la surface la
circonférence de la terre était d'autres
39000 375 km tollé mais ils nous
enlèvent des boues et on se retrouve à
30 mille kilomètres et donc les cartes
dont dont dispose colons sont des cartes
beaucoup plus réduite ou quand il se met
à palau dont il est parti il a
l'impression que la route de l'ouest est
beaucoup plus court alors pour rebondir
sur ce que vous avez dit le paradoxe
c'est que le globe de martin bea m
il est il a été remis aux commerçants de
nuremberg qui lui avait commandé parce
qu'ils voulaient eux même pouvoir
envoyer des bateaux en inde
il a été remis le 20 juin 14 192 or
colomb a découvert l'amérique le 12
octobre 14 192
c'est à dire c'est moi après donc a
priori on peut penser que colomb n'avait
pas la mappemonde où le globe de benny b
haïm
en fait comme je l' ai dit tout à
l'heure collomb avant de partir pour les
espagnols il a été à lisbonne parce
qu'il espérait que le roi jean 2 lui
financerez ses expéditions et c'est là
où il a rencontré b haïm et où il a
rencontré magellan et pendant des
soirées entières
ils avaient les cartes de données volées
mais ils avaient les cartes dali drissi
et il disait alors c'est quoi pour toi
la circonférence de la terre c'est con
et c est ben haim qui était un le
cartographe officielle du portugal avait
fait construire dans un palais un globe
gigantesque où il y avait des escaliers
des échelles et il proposait aux
navigateurs de venir voir le monde
représentée dans son palais en échange
de quoi les navigateurs au retour de
leur expédition devait apporter abm le
complément d'information et il est
possible
il est possible que que que bm et vont
où j'ai entendu parler de l'esc issoudun
continent américain et qu'il en ait
parlé à colon mais il l'a pas mis sur sa
carte
parce que ou sur son globe parce que
tant qu'on ne lui avaient pas confirmé
des visuels existence il ne voulait pas
qu'on lui reproche de l'avoir mis et il
ya un deuxième exemple qui est magellan
magellan il va partir soixante ans après
colons faire le premier tour du monde et
donc lui-même eux va passer par ce qui
deviendra le détroit de magellan et le
le secrétaire de magellan remercie dans
son livre il s'appelle piqué a fait ta b
haïm d'avoir indiqué le détroit de
magellan
enfin qui qu'on appelle les droits de
magellan or quand on prend le globe de
biya hymne
il n'y a pas plus de détroit de magellan
qu' il y a d'amérique pour colons alors
ce qui est intéressant c'est que quand
on prend la partie ouest
il ya quand même quelques petites îles
qui apparaissent et c'est notamment les
îles des açores et il faut savoir que le
beau-père de bîmes était le gouverneur
des açores est en fait la navigation
maritime ne s'était pratiquement pas un
n'avait pratiquement pas été au delà des
açores et du cap vert en ce qui concerne
l'ouest
et comme vous l'avez dit vous-même le
paradoxe de cette histoire c'est que
quand collomb est arrivé à haïti
il n'a jamais pensé qu'il avait
découvert un continent et il est mort
sans savoir que c'était lui qui avait
découvert l'amérique
mais lorsqu'elle est encore plus amusant
si l'on peut dire dans l'iss
2 que l'on sait qu'on ne vous a
popularisé l'idée que lui seul à
l'époque qui était assez intelligent
pour avoir compris que la terre était
ronde
quand on regarde le film de ridley scott
au moment du 500e anniversaire de la
conquête de l'amérique avec jarre
depardieu dans le rôle de christophe
colomb on voit gérard depardieu qui
explique à son fils que la terre est
ronde et qui souffre beaucoup que les
comités d'experts que qu'on lui oppose
lui dise non non non vous n'arriverez
jamais là-bas vous allez tous mourir
sous-entendu parce que ce sont des cas
ce sont tous des savants catholique
sous-entendu l'église catholique ne
savait pas encore que la terre était
ronde
évidemment tout ça est absurde tout le
monde savait que la terre était ronde
mais simplement eux avaient fait les
bons calculs
c'est à dire que christophe que l'on
sous-estimé la distance pour le japon à
peu près il avait ce qu'il avait calculé
c'était quatre fois moins que la réalité
pour arriver au japon et pourquoi je
l'océan pacifique est gigantesque
il aurait fallu qu'ils traversent et
l'atlantique et le pacifique ce qui l'a
sauvé au fond ce qui amène un continent
au milieu s'il n'avait pas eu le
continent au milieu il serait mort mais
il ya un point très intéressant que vous
venez de soulever c'est l'obscurantisme
de l'église catholique aux 15e 16e et
17e siècles parce que jusqu'à copernic
et galilée
si on disait que la terre était ronde et
vous étiez comme jordano bruno vous
aider vous étiez brûlé et vous aviez des
des moines prédicateur qui continue à
parcourir l'europe notamment un dénommé
cosmos et qui continuait à raconter que
la terre était supportée par des et le
ciel était supportée par des murailles
et et aider et des piliers et la grande
révolution ça et égaliser à deux niveaux
d'une part parce qu'il a dit que la
terre était ronde mais surtout parce
qu'il a dit que le soleil était au
centre de la planète et qu'on était plus
dans un système géocentrique mais dans
un système héliocentrique et ça ça a été
une révolution considérable puisque d'un
côté il a démontré que la terre tournait
sur elle même
et qui faisait une rotation de 360 jours
autour du soleil
ça montre le le champ d'expérimentation
immense de la géographie c'est à dire
que la géographie cc à la fois le cosmos
c'est à la fois la représentation de la
terre c'est à la fois l'explication des
phénomènes naturels et ça deviendra un
moyen de comprendre et d'expliquer les
conflits et l'évolution du monde
un dernier mot sur christophe colomb il
part du sud de l'espagne pour aller vers
le japon
il a atterrit finalement dans les
caraïbes
est-ce qu'il ne s'est pas trompé de
direction c'était un formidable
navigateur le temps qu'il a mis pour
arriver aux caraïbes est un temps
exceptionnel sachant qu'ils ne savaient
pas où ils allaient et il a pris
quasiment les meilleurs vent il était
formidable en tant que marin mais ce qui
s'est pas trompé de direction est ce
qu'il va pas trop vers le sud est et en
fait il est parti de paloschi en bas de
guadalupe dire et il a été tout droit et
donc c'était quand même l'orthodromie la
route la plus simple pour arriver le
plus vite possible c'était la route du
bon sens
voilà comme quoi le bon sens c'est pas
forcément ce qu'on voit sur la carte
alors dire toujours toujours aux mêmes
on arrive à mercator à sa fameuse
projection alors là on est au xvième
siècle un peu après la découverte de
l'amérique mercator
pourquoi est ce qu'il est si important
parce que parce que c'est le premier qui
a fait une projection sphérique du monde
sur une carte plane c'est à dire que il
faut quand même préciser que ça sur une
mappemonde et une mappemonde
c'est un drop présentation de deux
hémisphères et tandis qu tandis que les
cartes qu'on a vu jusqu'à maintenant
c'est des planisphères et la la la la la
la la la force de mercator c'est qu'il
arrive sur une surface plane à faire
comprendre
la sphére si tu l'as fait réciter du
monde et rapproche les méridiens au
niveau des pôles en utilisant des formes
rectangulaires et et réussit à
quadriller le monde en 100 kg est en 180
méridien et et en 180 latitude en
distinguant la partie nord et la partie
sud pour l'ailé les les latitudes et la
partie est et ouest pour les les
longitudes qui sont 360 pardon on voit
quel point les formes alors évidemment
c'est pas d'une précision extraordinaire
mais sachant qu'on en sait encore
relativement peu sur le contenu de ces
continents
c'est quand même extraordinaire ce que
ce que l'on voit là quand on voit
l'amérique du nord et l'amérique du sud
qu'on a relativement peu explorés à ce
moment là on s'est quand même assez fort
alors comment quand on regarde le globe
qui est à gauche il ya quand même une
énormité monstrueuse c'est à dire que il
représente l'australie qui serait
pratiquement aussi grosse que l'amérique
et c'est le premier à représenter
l'australie sur cette carte
héééé et c'est totalement
disproportionné et à ceux enfin au jour
où mercator selon non dans la projection
sphérique personne de koné l'australie
et c'est une pure imagination de
l'esprit et essai dans sa carte la
première anomalie et la deuxième
anomalie sais qui mais c'est lent il
s'appelle tape robbana beaucoup trop bas
sur l'autre l'autre hémisphère on voit
bien que on est encore tâtonne à ce
moment là mais on a une représentation
du monde qui commence à correspondre à
la nôtre et c'est pas par hasard si on
continue d'enseigner aux enfants
la géographie à partir des projections
de mercator force qu'on regarde et au
début ces cartes là qu'on nous après la
nuit sont fausses mais au fossé à partir
de lui qu'on a une représentation assez
proche de la réalité
il ya une autre raison il ya une autre
raison qui est fondamental c'est que en
fait c'est le premier à avoir dessiné
les fuseaux horaires et quand on a au
19e siècle définit les décalages entre
fuseaux horaires et autres on s'est
servi de la projection de mercator
justement pour établir la carte des
fuseaux horaires et les décalages
horaires entre les lélio alors il ya
encore beaucoup beaucoup de cartes dans
votre livre
laurent maréchaux on va pas tous qui a
gardé on va regarder deux une delà de la
france du xviiie siècle à l'époque de
turgot voilà une carte routière effluves
et fluvial de la france du xviiie siècle
c'est assez extraordinaire on l'a on
voit que c'est l'économie c'est c'est
une représentation où on peut se
déplacer
on sait comment on fait pour aller d'un
point à un autre
les fleuves sont importants tout comme
les routes si le xviiie siècle
là vraiment ça devient très précis alors
en fait ce qui est on peut se demander
pourquoi j'ai mis turgot dans dans ce
panthéon des grands géographe et en fait
la première partie de la géographie on
l'a vu avec les grecs c'est de savoir où
on se trouve
la deuxième partie on vient de le voir
avec les cartes maritimes sait comment
se déplacer et la troisième partie c'est
turgot qui se posent la question à quoi
sert la géographie et pour turgot qui
était intendant général et qui était le
père du libéralisme le bonheur ça doit
commencer par le progrès économique et
le progrès économique ça doit
s'accompagner de la libre circulation
des marchandises et aider et des denrées
et donc turgot premièrement a été le
premier à imposer le cadastre pour lever
l'impôt de manière équitable et
deuxièmement il s'est dit
mais mon roi il a besoin quand ils vont
investir pour construire des routes
quand il veut créer des canaux maritime
il a besoin de disposer d'une carte
géographique précise et il avait une
deuxième obsession c'est qu' il fallait
recenser les populations et recenser les
ressources naturelles et faire en sorte
que les populations et les ressources
naturelles puisse se trouver au même
endroit au bon moment et au besoin se
déplacer ou immigrés à l'intérieur et et
vous avez bien fait de choisir cette
carte parce qu'elle montre comment à la
fin du xviiie siècle la géographie est
devenu un instrument de gestion
administrative et économique et
permettait également au moment où on
allait se lancer dans dans dans des
guerres de lever la conscription et il
ya un autre point dont on n'a pas parlé
mais qui est intéressant aussi c'est que
parallèlement à cette géographie s'est
développée une géographie religieuse
parce que les évêques pour relever le
denier du culte il avait besoin de
connaître la répartition de leurs
diocèses où se trouvaient leurs
habitants et est imposé les malheureux
paysans en fonction de la surface de
leur propriété on a vu parallèlement une
géographie économique
une géographie militaire où il ya
quelques cartes dans le livre où on voit
comment les géographes des coupes la
france à la fois pour trouver des lieux
d'hébergement et construire des
citadelles rencontre des valets et y ait
enfin une géographie religieuse qui a
besoin de la géographie pour lever le
denier du culte et pour finir je crois
que c'est votre carte préférée parmi
toutes celles qui figurent dans ce livre
alors expliquez nous de qui elle est
d'abord c'est important et pourquoi est
ce que c'est celle que vous préférez
alors on a vu que la géographie avait
des fins économiques mais à un moment on
continuer à s'interroger sur la
compréhension du monde et jusqu'à
présent on s'était intéressée aux lieux
non ce n'était pas intéressé aux
correspondances n'étaient pas intéressés
à l'affluence
au climat on s'était pas intéressé à la
météorologiques et il ya un naturaliste
qui s'appelle alexandre vendre un bol
qui est né en 1769 qui lui va
révolutionner la géographie parce que il
va parcourir le monde à la fois pour
pour relever les températures pour
relever les spécimens pour relever les
plantes mais également pour essayer de
trouver des correspondances c'est à dire
que une fougère qui ramasse dans les
andes
il en a ramassé une similaire plusieurs
années avant en allemagne et il va
pouvoir faire une carte géographique qui
va être une carte des correspondances on
va pouvoir aux comprendre les cartes
météorologiques on va pouvoir comprendre
les cartes des climats et et pour ce
faire il va illustrer chacune de ces
cartes de la végétation qui qui qui
pousse donc à gauche on a une carte des
ondes
il est parti à pied il est monté jusqu'à
6000 300 m ensuite on a une carte des
canaries tenerife ensuite on a une carte
de l'himalaya et apprendre à une carte
des alpes et des pyrénées et on voit
donc que sur la totalité du globe
iliad il ya des correspondances en
termes de climat en termes de on le
verra également de structure géologique
est également
en terme de
voilà est ce que c'est pour tout ça vous
vient vous cette passion pour la
géographie pour les géographes alors ma
première passion c'est la lecture de
lecteurs je suis devenu voyageur parce
que j'ai voulu aller voir ce qui se
passait dans les livres que j'avais lu
que ce soit jacques london kessel conrad
et il se trouve que je me suis souvent
retrouvé dans des pays en guerre
j'étais en afghanistan j'ai été au liban
et en syrie et un moment et j'ai voulu
comprendre quelle était la cause de ces
conflits et et napoléon disait qu'un
état avait la politique de sa géographie
et est françois hollande à la fin de son
quinquennat
quand on lui demandait qu'est ce qui
avait été le plus important pour lui
disais c'est la géographie et je crois
que on ne peut pas et je vous êtes
journaliste on ne veut pas comprendre le
monde
si on ne commence pas à s'intéresser à
la géographie et il ya un grand
géographe qui s'appelle elisée reclus
qui disait que la géographie
c'était l'histoire dans l'espace mais
mais mais que l'histoire c'était la
géographie dans le temps et aujourd'hui
aussi vous prenez l'eau qui à rabat si
vous prenez la crimée si vous voulez
comprendre ces conflits et essayer
d'avoir une position objective
il faut commencer par
vous plongez sur les cas il ya une
deuxième raison c'est que le voyage
enfin la cartographie c'est un voyage
c'est à dire que c'est un moment
d'émerveillement permanent et quand on
est amoureux des voyages la cartographie
c'est le complément naturel grâce à vous
on a pu voir comment le monde s'était
constitué au travers de d'abord huit
siècles avec les grecs
et puis à 25 siècles aujourd'hui et
c'est un travail dans le temps on voit
le monde se dessiner est ce un travail
on retrouve le même émerveillement que
l'on a quand on voyage qu'on découvre le
monde
merci l'euro maréchaux je rappelle votre
livre les défricheurs du monde c'est
géographe qui ont dessiné la terre avec
une préface de jean de loisy
c'est paru au cherche midi merci de nous
avoir suivis et rendez vous au prochain
numéro
[Musique]